well i have
seen the first four episodes so i'm you
i'm glad i just watched them the other
day yesterday
it's a lot of fun i'm excited to finally
get to
you know from be familiar with the
characters see what the show is all
about
i uh i feel like i didn't know anything
before i watched it which i think is
really cool
i know it's like it's it's that kind of
it's kind of the
the you know you read you read tweets
and messages and things and thoughts of
people in anticipation of the show
coming out
and it's just kind of bizarre how wrong
um some of the guesses are
and i'm just kind of sitting back and
waiting waiting for everything to
unravel
to the public well when the opportunity
to
do this and to be a part of this reboot
became a possibility for you
what was your reaction since you are
somebody who had already seen
and were a fan of the original series
did that make you more excited or more
nervous about
pursuing a role on the show i don't
think i felt any any which way about it
just because i
i wasn't sure they'd even give me a
chance because i was 16 at the time
and we obviously know that gossip girl
isn't exactly the most
pg-13 tv series out there um
and now with it being on hbo max it's
obviously a little bit more risque
and um you know explicit because it's
you know it's not watered down because
it's not in a network so it's not on
like a tv
network so it's it's going to be a
little bit more elevated so
it was definitely in disbelief that they
even let me audition so
and then when i got it i was like oh my
god this is crazy but then i realized i
was playing 14 year olds so there's a
little bit more room to get away with
that
because you had watched the original
series after it first aired what was it
that made you
originally decide to watch it was it
just you had heard about it and thought
you wanted to check it out um
i definitely heard about it growing up
because i feel like
i feel like maybe my sisters watched it
i don't i don't think they ever
mentioned it really but
it's just kind of been around people
would reference it
and you know there was like blair means
everywhere and
and i was i'd never been aware of it i
was watching pretty little liars at the
time
but then i kind of i outgrew it and
it got a little bit dark and i'm just a
very it became like stressful to me to
watch pretty little liars because it was
kind of so like
thrillery um so i was like
i i was i wasn't like but i was thinking
what else can i watch
that's a little mindless and and
relaxing and calm and i was like
oh let me just watch all these rich
people get mad at each other
and it was awesome and it did just that
it was a perfect perfect escape
um and a really great distraction
and i'm grateful for that how do you
personally normally feel about reboots
and remakes and reimaginings is it
something that
you find yourself interested in do you
normally shy away from watching
i'm usually the first to shy away
honestly i'm usually
i hate to admit it but i am that person
um so when i found out they were doing a
reboot i was i was
first of all like had i seen it at that
yes yes i had um
i was i was what what what what do you
mean they're doing a reboot like this is
the original cast coming back
what's gonna happen with this and then
um
i obviously found out what the premise
was and i was like okay now i feel kind
of
i feel kind of silly for being so like
quick to shut it down
um but yeah uh
i'm usually probably the first person
though to
turn them turn the blind eye to a reboot
then you give it a chance and then
you're kind of like okay well maybe
i shouldn't have spoken too soon yeah
but then it does its job it wins you
over that's what it should do
exactly and most of the time it's not
really a reboot it's kind of just it's
not really remake it's kind of just
i mean this one at least isn't
continuation and it's just ten ten years
later
different worlds more current what was
your audition process like for this when
you
left the audition
or you know the first meeting that you
might have had on this
was it something that you had a good
feeling about were you convinced you'd
never get it are you someone who tries
to not think about auditions after you
do them
well here's the thing i never actually
read in the room for it
i sent in a tape end of 2019
went on like disappeared to uganda my
sister was getting married so me and my
family went back home
and spent a lovely month there um just
getting enveloped in culture and just
seeing my family again for for for the
first time in like
like five or six years so it was it was
incredible
and then i came back and got the news
and i was in disbelief of course but
also
a little bit skeptical because i hadn't
done a call back i hadn't read in the
room for it
i was i was a little bit nervous that
they wouldn't really like me once i got
on set
or that something would go wrong and
then of course covet happened
and then i i was thinking okay well this
is done this isn't gonna happen
nice knowing you guys really great
meeting you but then cut to seven months
later we got
into it and we're in new york and we're
working on it and it's awesome
so it was a quick and easy process for
me yeah thank god
so you didn't have to be tortured over
whether or not you would get it for too
long
yes um i just had to be tortured on
whether or not it was happening
yeah which was probably almost worse
yeah um yeah but oh i'm glad those days
are behind me right now
you previously said that when you booked
the show you sort of
realized that acting was something you
could potentially do for the rest of
your life so
now that you've been doing the show
has that really confirmed that for you
even more
absolutely i feel like every single day
on set
um i enjoy it more
you know and with reading the scripts
and stuff i'm just
now being on this show and kind of
getting the seeing how everything works
and you know being really involved with
behind the scenes and
kind of and that stuff like that i just
crave more now
it's almost like it's like an addiction
i i just want to do more i want to push
myself and i want to challenge myself to
kind of
step more outside the boxes and and play
like far characters for myself so i
think yeah
if anything i've got i've got the bug
for sure what can you say to
to tease the story arc for the first
season what do you think are
the biggest ways the audience of the
show will be surprised by the story
you're telling
the story we're telling um
this is going to come out after the
first episode right yeah
we'll keep anything spoilery until after
it would be spoilery
okay okay cool um
[Music]
i think that the audience is really
gonna enjoy
getting a peek into the inner workings
of gossip girl
and the trials and tribulations of being
um this sort of uh like big sister
looking over the shoulder the shoulder
vibe
of gossip girl because in the original
it was just kind of
very one-dimensional and that she was
just this character that would just blog
and your stuff was and then it kind of
played with who she was and
her identity and all this stuff but now
first episode
it's like revealed and the the audience
is in on something that the characters
aren't
which i think is really really it was
such a cool way to
kind of flip the script a little bit um
so it kind of makes the audience feel
part of it all and that they know
something that we don't and it's
i don't know if i don't know if i was
giving too much away but um
i know what i am allowed to say is that
there's a lot of events there's a lot of
fashion
and there's literally a fashion show in
the first episode there's a black tie
gala in the second
i mean yeah they're in for a ride i mean
every single episode has a beginning
middle end and it was drama
drama
because there are two female characters
at the center of the story
people are going to look for comparisons
to serena and blair but it feels like
your character is much more the dan of
the story
is that how you see it too
at least initially i did see it like
that initially because
the the script i auditioned with was
very bad it was very
um new girl didn't really like the
you know the elitism of the of the world
that she was in
and so i definitely did think that but i
also feel like now
with you know me and jordan or me and
jordan's characters being half sisters
there's obviously going to be that kind
of comparison
they i think the audience is going to
expect it to be
very much me versus her or her versus me
whereas like it's not like that at all
because we actually
want to be sisters like we want to be
that family we want to have that
connection
and i think because we are still so
young and have to kind of overcome these
barriers in order to get there at the
end of the day
um i i mean me and jordan have
had endless conversations about this
because we know what the
um what the initial response would be
when two girls are put
are put up together you know there
always has to be kind of like a who
versus who and
we're very secure in the fact that
julian and zoya and myself and jordan
are um kind of
aware enough of ourselves to overcome
that
and and kind of uh
yeah be good at the end of the day
yeah yeah what are you enjoying about
that sister dynamic because it seems
like
you know these are two girls from very
different worlds and they're
still getting to know each other at the
same time the audience is getting to
know them
what are you enjoying about getting to
explore that dynamic as it grows more
and more
um well i actually have two sisters back
home
in vancouver and i miss them very very
much but
um jordan has kind of been an extension
of
of like a big sister to me in real life
and
um so that's kind of been really really
easy to tap into um
but sorry what was the second part of
your question oh just what you enjoy
about getting to explore that especially
as it's evolving because even in just
the first four episodes their
relationship dynamic keeps changing
i mean okay so all my sisters are older
right and so it's kind of
i mean jordan is older too but julian is
only a few years older than joya
and so it's interesting going to school
with your sister
but also having this kind of
separation and that you didn't know each
other for however long but your sisters
so you have to kind of
you know you're you're
kind of holding on to this thing that
you your family and your blood and
there's there's got to be some there's
just something there
you know there's just a connection there
and
trying to kind of explore that and see
how how really deep it is or how deep it
can be
and how far it can go is probably
the most exciting part for me because
it's going to go up and down i just i
just can't wait to see where it ends up
it's interesting too because she is the
the one whose
home life is very different from these
other kids
you also enjoy getting to explore that
duality in her life to have this very
different life at school that she's
living and with these
people that she's sort of friends with
now and then going home to a
very different home life yeah i mean
she and her dad right now are are
staying in there
in her grandmother's rent-controlled
apartment
um but it's in the upper west side and
she's kind of living this like lower
middle class life but also on the brink
of
actually not having a home um
so it's it's interesting
but like the place is nice but it's not
fancy so whenever she does go to these
like extreme environments she's
sure impressed by you know the decorum
of it all but
at the end of the day she's she's not
gonna
or at least i don't i don't think so yet
she's not gonna
kind of bash her home life because she's
like exposed to this kind of higher
um higher than thou lifestyle
um but her father is also a lawyer and
he's kind of like the moral compass of
the show
um because he's very like this is the
law you must be doing
but also they just have a really great
relationship but it's definitely
still father and daughter whereas i
think um
julian and davis have kind of like more
of like a pal
relationship yeah how does
zoya feel about gossip girl does she
care about finding out who gossip girl
is
what is that like for her to deal with
um i say this in pretty much every
single interview but zoya is somebody
who values
the well-being of her of her friends and
family and the people that she loves
so i don't think she really cares about
it
so much as about in terms of herself
like if it was
you know other than the exception of a
few traumatic events that have happened
to her
if it was kind of bashing her just to
you know rumors or whatever she wouldn't
really care about it
but when it you know gets in terms of
her
in her her family and her friends that's
when she really really would
um get riled up and really want to find
out and get to the bottom of it
she's just really annoyed because
it only it gets really real when it's
messing with the people that she loves
because she just really wants everybody
around her to be
to be happy and to be okay have you
finished filming the series now no
we finished i think early early
september so i think
um at some point the first week of
september we're done so you don't know
then
where exactly things will end up exactly
i
i know we're filming the ninth episode
right now and that's about as much as i
know
um so it's just kind of a i mean we have
a general idea josh will throw us little
hints here and there of where it's gonna
go
but um you never really get the full
picture
until you're filming the episode yeah
yeah i mean what is that relationship
like with him
as far as like how collaborative does it
get do you give
input on your character how much do you
get told about things
i truly i have nothing bad to say about
josh and working with him
um he's always receptive to any ideas or
any questions and concerns that i have
he lets me play with the character and
kind of add nuances and lets me make her
messy because
you know humans aren't perfect and
especially
um someone is comfortable with herself
as she is as zoya is
she um
she she's messy and i feel like a lot of
um
black characters or people of color
aren't allowed to be messy on tv because
it's kind of
you're either this prim and proper and
with like you know strict upbringing and
you have to
stick to the script and be perfect and
go to you know
post secondary and graduate and do all
this stuff or if you're even remotely
like
messy or you know just want to go out
like a messy bun or something
or then put on this end of the spectrum
where you're like too hood or you're
um um no i'm i'm so
serious like this is it's it's the
tropes you know you can't
or you're the background character and
there just isn't enough time to even
explore your story exactly
exactly you don't get an arc yeah it's
it's
it's really frustrating to see that in
in in the industry and of course i
am very much i very much recognize my
privilege and
you know in being a person of color but
also a mixed person of color
um i'm trying to
be very much aware of that while also
making it acceptable for people of color
to be messy on tv
because it's real i mean you know we
don't have our hair snatched all the
time and
we have bad hair days you know what i'm
saying and we are allowed to be messy
and go out and sweat pants in a messy
bun and like not be ratchet you know
so i just i think it's really really
awesome that he lets us play with that
and
you know go to sleep and do rags and
sleeping and heads clubs and
um bonnets or whatever we need to so
um we're gonna try to keep pushing
pushing further and pushing that line
further but
yeah he's the entire the entire crew so
far has been
incredible to work with so i'm very
thankful for that
yeah and i feel like teenagers are
especially messy so
exactly yeah absolutely yeah it's
definitely appropriate
well you mentioned the fashion and
fashion was
a huge part of the original series and
it seems like it's also
a defining characteristic of this series
how do you feel about her specific
wardrobe from how she
styles her school uniform to what she
wears in everyday life to when
she dresses up do you feel like there is
one way to describe her style
or is it more of a mix of things
i think she expresses herself mostly
through
or i think she she sees herself mostly
in
in in artwork
so she sees herself in books and plays
and music
and you know
um you know paintings or art you know
she doesn't so much express herself in
her clothing she just kind of goes for
whatever's comfortable which i'm
learning as i as i continue because at
first i was
thinking oh she's cool she just wears
street clothes she's very into style
yadda yadda but
the more and more i learned about her i
think she's just
um she connects more with arts than she
does with
outer expression she just kind of wears
whatever is comfortable and whatever
she feels good feels good on her that
day
i just i like even just what she does
with her school uniform because
she definitely seems like she makes it
much more comfortable than some of the
other people exactly
absolutely yeah she's not really looking
to impress anybody she just wants to
feel good
pretty early on there's also some
tension between these sisters
over a guy so when it comes
i mean they're teenagers so i mean can
you blame him
between these two fly people and just
not and not expect them to you know have
some self-doubt come on
what a great major yeah when it comes to
your character and
and obie how do you feel about the
relationship
is it a situation like do you worry that
she shouldn't even be
looking in that direction or is it fair
game because
you know her sister and him are have
become so different
um i think that's a very very
tough question to answer um it's
obviously very very subjective
but when you're young
um listen to me preaching like i'm like
i'm like i've lived a life i'm literally
18.
but um i feel like things definitely
feel more
heightened when you're young and so
this is kind of her first you know real
intimate
interaction with somebody who happens to
have fallen for her sister also
so it's probably a little bit
uncomfortable but also
you'll see as the episodes go on that
there's this kind of
mutual awareness of how over it is you
know
and from obi's perspective i just it was
a little bit weird because
in my head i was thinking wow he just
sees something shiny and just
you know goes after it you know just so
anything anything
because he's so guilty of his
um kind of privilege and his
wealth and all of this and i think it
was a little bit like
in my head i was thinking of course um
sees one you know somebody who's
abnormal not a part of his world and
just needs to
just you know no matter how real and how
authentic
it felt to him um i think it's just a
barrier that he needed to
for himself in order to grow he just he
just needed to kind of
do that and like try to get and learn
from it
and then continues on but
yeah i definitely felt a little bit
weird about dating my best friends
my my sister's brother or my sister's
boyfriend
um but you know it happens in real life
and
julian was pretty chill about it because
i think she she was very well aware that
she was a little bit controlling and
the chemistry between them had kind of
dispersed
yeah i mean we learned pretty quickly
that they are very different and
character has much more in common with
him but i think because that happens it
helps julian find herself and even
though it's to the detriment of zoya
yeah um i think it needed to happen in
order for
julian to grow in order for them to grow
as a couple together
um if they ever get back together i
don't know i really like how
this series is tackling issues i mean
you know we see
the way that bullying is is handled
there's different
issues that are obviously taken on in
the show
do you like how the show is handling
that side of things and and
issues that you are able to tackle with
the show like this
i think in the beginning i was a little
bit frustrated at how quickly
some of them were skimmed over um
but when you're making a 45 minute tv
show with the beginning middle and
end with following different story lines
you're not going to really get to the
nitty-gritty of every single
um issue right and so
while i think we do cover a lot of
issues i mean
you could go on you know what i'm saying
we can make an entire season about
bullying and and you know high school
drama and all of this stuff
but there's just so much going on all
the time which i feel like
would take away from not take away but
um yeah
it's just it's i was i understand it and
so
i i appreciate that we're even touching
on issues at all period
um you've got to take it
for what it is and and you know read
them read in between the lines
yeah because you're always going to do a
little bit you can always come back to
it in future seasons because
you know obviously exactly i mean also
like gossip girl is all about the drama
and all that
right so we're just kind of trying to
like micro dose
little inklings of advice and and touch
on issues and
important things while also still
you know staying true to the gospel
nature and you know
the oblivion of the rich
as someone who is a fan of the original
series do you get
excited about the little connections
that pop up between
the original and this one do they get
do they get pointed out to you ahead of
time or do you just get to like
stumble across them in a script when you
get them um i just stumble i stumble and
i get
oh my goodness i cannot wait for
the fourth episode to come out because
there is a
huge huge reference to the old show
that i think everybody's gonna love um
so i'm excited to see what everybody
thinks about that i'm not really on
twitter but i will be on twitter for
that
um yeah there's definitely little
dosages and little
um little easter eggs for the eagle-eyed
gossip girl fans out there yeah i love
that moment
in that episode because i was like okay
so they're going there yeah
yeah yeah yeah do you feel like
the last thing i want to ask you then do
you feel like you're you are prepared
for
everything this show is going to bring
for you and
i mean do you have do you feel like you
have any sort of a like a real grasp
on what that's gonna do um
no i'm not ready for it i don't think
it's something that you can prepare for
in fact i think i'm avoiding feeling
anything about it um because i
like i said earlier i am somebody who
really really values my privacy and my
personal space
and the relationships and people that
are close to me and so
kind of the the fear and the
anticipation of losing a tiny chunk of
my anonymity is
probably thinking about that too much
would probably send me over the edge
so we're gonna take it by take it take
it step by step and um
and see where it goes
well i am excited to see where the show
goes i'm having so much fun with it
already and i think this cast is just so
interesting i thought you were just
terrific in the show
so wow i am excited to see more it's fun
there's some fun characters and story
lines and i like some of the little
twists
you guys are doing so yeah i am
i'm a little afraid for a whole season
with everybody because
i feel like yeah there's no way these
characters are coming out of this
unscathed
but i truly don't know if anybody's
ready yeah nobody's ready
you may think that you are but there's a
lot going on
and it's it's weird like
um when i got the screener my best
friend paloma's obviously with me and so
we watched it together
but it was weird because i watched her
reaction to the show
and because she didn't really if once
you're
if you're in in it and you do an
interview and you kind of read something
you're like oh
they just exposed the entire storyline
it's because you're like so immersed in
it that you can't even think about
how people who are reading it are
receiving it
as um so it's interesting kind of
getting an outsider's
perspective and i'm like oh so that's
what it looks like from out there
got it i think there'll be some fun
conversations on twitter
so absolutely boy oh boy i know plum is
gonna be all over it
well thank you for talking to me i
appreciate it
this is awesome thank you so much thanks
a lot